ellen pompeo comes in at number eight
on our highest paid actress list with 19
million dollars in earnings this year
[Music]
but her career didn't start with her
starring role on grey's anatomy she was
born in everett massachusetts a suburb
right outside
boston the youngest of four children her
mother passed away when pompeo was a
little girl
leaving pompeo's dad to raise her and
her siblings
pompeo moved to new york city where she
was first discovered while bartending at
a soho bar
she originally thought that the
hollywood agent was just trying to pick
her
up but it actually turned out to be
quite legit
she got her first full-length movie
credit as upset girl in the 1999 movie
coming soon this led to her more
prominent roles in blockbuster films
did that guy just call you the godfather
are you my deadhead but pompeo is most
famous for her role as meredith gray
the fierce surgeon on grey's anatomy
currently on its 17th season
only six women out of 20. when the show
started in 2005
no one had any idea she'd become a
household name for playing a
self-proclaimed
really good fake doctor
abc's graze has reportedly generated
nearly 3 billion dollars for parent
company disney by 2018
in 2006 cable network lifetime licensed
the show for syndication at 1.2 million
dollars an episode
the series has since been licensed for
streaming domestically and
internationally
for pompeo who earns a percentage of the
profit generated by the show
syndication cash flow means higher
earnings and despite the massive gender
pay gap we so
often see in hollywood and pretty much
everywhere else
she's made it her mission to stand up
for herself
in 2017 she negotiated a salary of over
000 per episode a cut of the show's
profit
as well as a producer title that means
she can earn an extra
6 million dollars per year beyond her
per episode salary
she's close with the show's creator
shonda rhimes
pompeo acts as an executive producer for
another shonda rhimes show
grey's anatomy spin-off station 19.
pompeo keeps it real as the personal
assistant to her three children
and she has a lot of fun on twitter
replying to fans
her most famous fan taylor swift who
named her cat meredith gray
even giving pompeo a cameo in her music
video
pompeo fanatics can look forward to
watching all of the drama unfold at
grace lone memorial hospital
when season 17 premieres later this year
you